a spanking starship and one of the great
pleasures associated with this position
is the opportunity to recruit and
introduce without spending lecture for
the annual space travel at their lecture
as I was thinking this morning about
appropriate things to say to introduce
Jeff Hoffman and at the same time trying
to eat my breakfast and read the faces I
saw in the New York Times with another
set of absolutely mind-blowing images
taken from the Hubble Space Telescope
and as many of you are aware one of the
people who has proud for the kids Prime
credit for the repair of the Space
Telescope is our speaker today Jeff Oh
Jeff is breech has returned to MIT after
a long long trip including five voyages
into space as a science astronauts
mission specialist with the National
Aeronautics and Space Administration
pardon that time Jeff was here at the
Center for Space Research as a radio
astronomer x-ray x-ray and x-ray
well aroma
astronomer he received his PhD at
Harvard was the undergraduate their
numbers dollars was also bid from an
honor to us today on the subject of 21st
century space exploration with humans
and robots 13th
[Music]
[Applause]
NASA's budgets are tight and the fact
that I'm here means that we don't have
any travel expenses for this space grant
lecture so that's a big step in the
right direction I noticed for the
department lunch they served some petit
fours now before I came here after I had
left the astronaut office I actually
spent four years in France representing
NASA in Europe working at the u.s.
embassy and it was nice to see the petit
fours for lunch but then I realized that
here it is May 1st and we're all here
working so there's no question that
we're not in France anymore but this is
actually my my first big lecture here at
MIT to the department and and other
people so I'm really I'm delighted to be
able to share some of my views on
exploring space which is what I really
consider I've devoted a major part of my
my life's work to and since I'm going to
discuss the role of humans and robots in
the exploration of space
I should explain at the beginning that I
consider exploration to be everything
that expands the realm of human
experience and of human consciousness
and despite having devoted a major part
of my career to human spaceflight I want
to state at the beginning my belief that
the vast majority of space exploration
has been and always will be performed by
machines and so it's important to
appreciate the uniqueness of our bio
chemical based minds but at the same
time to understand how our minds
interact with machines to project our
consciousness to regions that we can't
physically explore because exploration
doesn't have to be physical I started my
professional career as Larry said as an
astronomer and I've always considered
astronomy to be exploration even though
astronomy by definition is the study of
wherever it is that you are not and
while astronomy may be passive compared
to actual physical exploration I like to
remind people that while Columbus a
great Explorer gave us a new continent
Galileo actually gave us whole new
worlds and Galileo as you may know never
set foot outside Italy and in our
lifetime as human beings we've explored
the surfaces of all these worlds that
Galileo discovered and many others
besides and we've never physically
traveled any farther than our own moon
so if our telescopes in some sense are
the metaphorical vessels which carry our
minds out to the Stars then it's
certainly fair to say that Hubble is the
flagship of the fleet because it has
taken us deep into space and back in
time to the youth of our universe we've
all seen this famous Deep Field
photograph which was taken by having
Hubble point into a tiny part of the sky
which as far as other telescopes were
concerned was basically empty and of
course it revealed a multitude of unseen
galaxies very far away and I show it as
a reminder that I mean if this is not
exploration and I certainly don't know
what is
and of course Hubble has many partners
up in space exploring at other
wavelengths as well as very powerful
partners on the ground which are using
some incredible techniques to penetrate
the atmosphere which I think would seem
almost like magic to Galileo or even to
Hubble now an important theme of my talk
is going to be that exploration goes
beyond just scientific research into
other realms of human experience and
this is certainly true for astronomy
which engages not only our scientific
curiosity but other aspects of our
humanity our intellects as they travel
far away with the ever-increasing gaze
of our telescope but I think they bring
our emotions and our spirits with us and
that's why we get on the front page of
the New York Times pictures of the
Hubble telescope that's why the public
has responded with such enthusiasm to
these magnificent pictures like this
famous picture which I look at as a
picture almost of creation itself it's
the biblical let there be light if you
will
well I've begun my talk briefly by
talking about astronomy because that's
where I began my own interest in space
and my career but I don't propose to
dwell on this aspect of space
exploration except to mention my own
very good fortune in having played a
role in repairing the initially flawed
Hubble telescope and this will be a
jumping-off point for some of my
observations about humans and robotics
having been both an astronomer and an
astronaut for me one of the most
satisfying aspects of working on Hubble
was being able to unite the world of
space astronomy which generally prefers
automated spacecraft with the world of
human spaceflight which I've come to
know quite well through my own personal
experience and despite my statement at
the beginning about the importance of
machines in exploring space I do feel
strongly about the value of human
presence and I intend to talk about the
human experience of spaceflight and the
human dimension of space exploration but
not in the context of man versus machine
or humans versus robots which I really
consider to be a false conflict robots
like all other machines are tools we use
them to expand our physical capabilities
when we work with them and we use them
to operate remotely in places that we
cannot go ourselves and the relations of
humans and machines has certainly
evolved as our machines have become more
sophisticated and this evolution will
undoubtedly continue with great benefits
for the exploration of space in which
telescopes and satellites probes robots
and humans all have roles to play now
when people first find out that I'm an
astronaut almost inevitably the question
that they asked me before any others is
what's it like in space it's a very
simple question but think about it for a
minute what's it like in space this is a
very human question that we would never
think of asking a machine even though
our automated space probes do a superb
job of measuring temperatures and
pressures and many other aspects of
their environment and this though is not
what people are asking they want to know
what is it like to be in space our
probes send back data but humans can
share experience a very important part
of the tradition of exploration is to
report on your travels your discoveries
to share your experiences with other
people and ideally to make the new
territory that you explore part of human
culture and human consciousness so
before I talk about robotics let me
honor this tradition of exploration and
share a little bit some of the human
experiences of this new environment of
space my first spaceflight which was in
April of 1985 made me the 160 second
human space traveler of which the four
hundredth blasted off just a little over
a year ago now this is a large enough
number of people to make going into
space perhaps no longer the cutting-edge
exploration that it once was but
nevertheless anybody who's sitting on
top of a loaded rocket ready to make
their first trip into space can very
rightly feel that they are embarking on
a personal journey of discovery and
exploration now after all you can
explore a new environment for yourself
even if you are not the first human
being to go there so what do you see and
feel and do when you go into space well
first of all it is an absolutely
incredible ride now I hope that someday
we're gonna have gentler and safer ways
of getting into space cheaper as well in
a sense I'd like to think that two of my
flights which were devoted to testing
the tethered satellite system combined
with advances in carbon nanotube
technology and certainly some imagined
of engineering will ultimately lead to a
space elevator such as arthur c clarke
described in his book The Fountains of
paradise which I strongly recommend if
you're interested in tethers and
elevators in space I mean wouldn't it be
great to go into a cabin and press the
42 K button and then a few hours later
you step out and you're at geostationary
orbit certainly I mean the long-term
exploration and utilization of space
absolutely depends on making access
safer and cheaper but for now if you
like excitement well it is a pretty
great adrenaline rush when the boosters
light and the ground falls straight away
from you and you break the sound barrier
in 45 seconds going straight up and then
just in another few minutes the big blue
sky of Earth has turned into the
blackness of space and there you are
and you look out the window and the
first thing that you notice is that your
whole perspective has changed you fly in
an airplane and you look out and you can
see entire cities below you but from an
orbiting spacecraft you can see
countries or even whole continents like
the Himalayas and Tibet here to the
right India to the left I'll never
forget during our Hubble mission where
we were up at 600 kilometers which is
about as high as the shuttle ever goes
and we were flying right over Houston in
the middle of the night and I could look
out one window and see the lights of Los
Angeles and the other window at the same
time and see the lights of the East
Coast with Washington New York and
Boston now during that Hubble mission we
were pretty busy but every once in a
while we had to wait a few minutes while
we were outside while the ground did
some checks on a piece of
instrumentation that we had just
installed and during one of those
moments the arm operator flew me out
over the wing so that I could take a
photograph of what the entire payload
Bay looked like so I could share with
people an astronauts eye view of what
it's like being in space
now this is not an advertisement for the
Flat Earth Society I can tell you from
personal experience the earth is round I
circle it every 90 minutes but of course
wide-angle lenses produce some
interesting optical effects as does
actually the highly curved reflective
surface of the telescope itself my
favorite of those image is this one
which I call the transparent Hubble
telescope so you can see the earth right
through the telescope and I will leave
the explanation as an exercise for the
students but for everybody as you look
at these pictures quite seriously try to
think about how would you program a
robot to look for humor in the
environment that it's exploring or
beauty for that matter and talking of
beauty when we installed new
magnetometers we had to go all the way
up to the top of the telescope which was
about 15 meters I don't know whether to
say above the shuttle because you can
see the earth down below us but in any
case we were moving pretty far away from
our home territory and for me this was
one of the most spectacular and
emotional moments that I experienced in
space because I mean there I was I'm the
one with the red stripes around their
legs and I was floating between heaven
and earth really attached to the arm
just by a slack stainless steel cable
and every few minutes again when we had
a little bit of spare time while they
were doing the checkout on the new
magnetometers I could let go and become
a free floating satellite and it was
really quite an extraordinary feeling
especially if I turn my back to the
shuttle in which case I really had the
feeling of kind of being lost in space
which was quite exhilarating but
certainly no place to be for anybody who
suffers from vertigo and I'll remind you
that crews who were going to be space
walking outside the International Space
Shuttle are going to see the shuttle
even farther away than we did as the
station gets bigger and bigger so that's
a little bit about what it looks like in
space what about the question of how
does it feel in space which is obviously
more subjective and harder to
communicate well I'm sure you can
appreciate the
initial euphoria that I felt as soon as
the engines shut down after my first
launch because after all those years of
dreaming and waiting I was actually in
orbit and weightless in space I actually
couldn't stop smiling for about 15
minutes I looked out the window to see
how fast we were going but of course
there's no wind there's no noise there's
no vibration and so there's no real
feeling of speed but nevertheless when
you fly over San Francisco and you look
at your watch and 10 minutes later
you're over Cape Cod I mean you know
you're going fast now there are some
very strong physical sensations involved
in the initial experience of
weightlessness not all of them pleasant
right when the engines shut off I felt
like I was hanging upside down now of
course there is no up or down in space
but that's the sensation you get because
without gravity pulling blood down into
your legs it does tend to rush up into
your head I'm sure everybody here is
probably hung upside down for a little
while but have you tried doing it for
hours or days I mean you can get quite a
headache really and also when you
release gravity's pressure on your
spinal column it actually increases its
height by an inch or two which may be
very ego boosting if you're just a tad
under six feet but it probably has a
physical effect similar to what happens
when they put people on medieval torture
racks and tried to stretch them and then
of course there's space sickness which
results from a total confusion of your
body's vestibular system which is
responsible for maintaining your balance
here on earth and suffers from the lack
of the expected gravity induced cues
when you get up into orbit now actually
we can treat most of these unpleasant
symptoms pharmacologically but you
should realize that the initial
accommodation to weightlessness does
involve significant stress but humans
are remarkably adaptable and after a few
days in space just about everybody gets
over the initial problems of adapting to
this new environment
and starts really enjoying the
experience of actually being in space
floating weightless looking at the world
beneath you space all around you and
everybody of course reacts in their own
way but I've found that being in orbit
almost universally evokes a sense of awe
real awe in the deepest sense of the
will of the word I love climbing
mountains and and for me I think it's
not dissimilar to what a lot of people
feel when they go into the high
mountains where you have to work hard in
an unforgiving environment and take
certain risks to gain the summit and on
the high ground your view is expanded
your mind is kind of cleared but of
course space is higher than the highest
mountaintop and the environment is even
more unforgiving and the most powerful
and unique feeling in Space Flight you
cannot get on a mountaintop and that's
the physical freedom of weightlessness
itself which is an utter delight I mean
for me the weightless experience goes
beyond being just physical it has
psychological emotional and maybe even
spiritual dimensions and unfortunately
we don't really possess the language to
adequately express this because we don't
have the shared experience and I find
that even pictures can't really convey
the inner feeling of weightlessness so I
try to use pictures symbolically have
you ever dreamed of flying a lot of
people do but this magic carpet is not
an illusion I mean we do it
weightlessness gives you this wonderful
sense of freedom it's an ability to do
outrageous things which you can barely
imagine on the earth and this joy of
weightlessness is one of the main
reasons that I believe that humanity
really has a future in space because I'm
convinced that large numbers of people
are going to want to explore space
personally and they'll be willing to pay
to do it and they won't be content just
to send robots and actually the
development of the infrastructure
necessary to transport and support large
numbers of people in space will end up
being a huge boon for space exploration
beyond Earth orbit now I have to make a
disclaimer I still work for NASA
I have to remind you that NASA does not
send me or my colleagues up into space
so that we can see beautiful views or
experience the physical bliss of
weightlessness there's no question I
mean I'll carry moments like this in my
memory for all my life but we were sent
up there to do important work on all of
our flights and I'm glad to say that we
did nowadays the work that most
astronauts are engaged in when they go
into space involves the International
Space Station now my talk formally is
about space exploration and I have to
say that what we're doing in low-earth
orbit these days is in a sense not so
much about exploring as learning how to
live in space comfortably and take
advantage of this unique environment
while at the same time trying to figure
out eventually how to explore further
away from the earth but since the space
station is human spaceflight at least
for the foreseeable future I should make
some comments about it first of all
scientific experimentation is one of the
primary functions of the space station
and most of us have worked in
laboratories on the earth here and we
know what it's like to conceive and
develop and carry out new experiments
when we find ourselves faced with
repetitive tasks we generally try to
automate the process because nobody
likes to waste time but we don't
automate laboratory experiments until we
thoroughly understand the systems and
we've worked out all the bugs because
it's almost always the case that during
the initial phases of getting a new
experiment working there are surprises
and when you have to do a lot of
troubleshooting you need to be
personally involved with your equipment
the time for automation is when you
understand the hardware and the software
and the processes and that's how to rest
your laboratories work we all understand
that and I have to say that it amazes me
when I hear people saying that
laboratory type research on the space
station could just as easily be carried
out automatically as by having humans
involved now as I said scientific
research is an important goal of the
space station
but it's certainly not the only one the
station is going to be used to
extensively as a testbed for new space
technologies I hope such as being able
to try out more efficient solar power
generation systems for example or
deployment mechanisms for large foldable
antennas or closer to home control
algorithms for large multi satellite
constellations before we have to commit
to using these technologies for new and
expensive autonomous systems but of all
the things that I hope the new space
station B can become the most important
is as a testbed for new space robotic
technology because this is going to be
one big space station now we're gonna
work hard to figure out how to increase
the number of people living and working
here but even if we had 10 people on
board when you look at all the
laboratories that are imagined for here
if we really fill up all this lab space
with experiments then robotic technology
is going to be absolutely essential to
allow human beings to fully utilize the
opportunities that the station presents
and of course robotic technology is also
going to be essential to eventually
allow us to explore further away from
Earth this is the place where we should
be testing robotic servicing techniques
that eventually we can use to allow
repair robots to go out to the earth-sun
Lagrangian points for instance to
service what we expect in a decade or so
are gonna be fleets of astronomical
solar and Earth observing satellites
much in the same way that we astronauts
serviced Hubble now after we repaired
the Hubble Space Telescope I was often
asked whether robots couldn't have
performed this these repairs as well as
we did well the answer was and still is
no they could not neither then nor now
do we have space robots sophisticated
enough or with sufficient tactile
capability to do a lot of the fine work
we carried out as an example replacing
the solar array drive electronics
we were dealing with tiny non captive
screws on the back of the electronic
connectors which kept coming loose and
they were floating all over the place
like a swarm of flies and we had to keep
grabbing them with our fingertips
putting them in the trash bag and
eventually chasing one of them with me
on the end of the arm hanging out it was
quite exciting certainly nothing that we
were expecting and and way beyond the
capability of any robotic system right
now however I hope that this is not
always going to be true as I said robots
are tools and the better our tools are
the more useful work we can do with them
let me introduce you to Robonaut which
is a research project underway at the
Johnson Space Center and they're
connected with a lot of university
groups in including some people here at
MIT the idea here was to make an
anthropomorphic robot that could use the
same tools that evie a astronauts use so
you don't have to develop a whole new
robotic tool suite and I visited the
laboratory several times the results I
have to say are very impressive expect
especially the dexterity at the hand the
guy who was the chief designer here
actually gave a talk at the American
Society of hand surgeons my brother is a
is an orthopedic surgeon specializes in
hand and he heard a many he said it was
absolutely fascinating the way that
they've built similar tendons and and
actuators to really try to mimic the
motions of the human hand and I saw a
very impressive demonstration in the lab
of Robonaut actually using an e V a
tether clamp to put on and off a hook
and and I have to tell you this is not
an easy thing to do with a with an e VA
glove on and Robonaut was able to do it
the biggest limitation currently is the
lack of an effective force feedback
system and the operator told me that
when he went to grasp something he had
to use primarily visual feedback and
that it was really like trying to work
with what it would probably be trying to
work if with your hands being totally
numbed by a local anesthetic where you
really can't feel anything
and you have to work just by what you
can see there are forced feedback
systems available but currently they're
much too bulky and not nearly as
sensitive as our human nervous system
but progress is being made and hopefully
the situation will improve and I
certainly look forward to some day
seeing Robonaut get a test flight on the
International Space Station because if
we don't eventually have robots capable
of the sort of repair work that we did
on the Hubble Space Telescope then that
will mean that progress in robotic
technology will have stalled out which
would be a huge pity for Space
Exploration because no matter how much
progress we make in human spaceflight
there are always going to be places that
we cannot go ourselves physically and
the better robots we have the more
sophisticated exploration we're going to
be able to carry out now there's another
area where human presence has an
advantage and this transcends just being
able to manipulate things manually while
repairing Hubble we had several
surprises that forced us to adopt
procedures that were completely
different from those planned before the
mission or suggested in real time by
Mission Control for example these doors
that you see underneath the wide field
planetary camera which contain the
gyroscope compartment we opened them the
first day we went out there and then
when I went to close them they wouldn't
close and that would have absolutely
crippled the telescope if they were left
open and so I spent about a half hour
playing with the doors trying to figure
out what the problem was
and it was hard to figure out what we
were going to have to do it it required
a combination of looking from lots of
different angles feeling how the
different latches were engaging wiggling
things and also and here it gets a
little bit more complicated to explain
but somehow after doing all these things
then being able to sort of to step back
and and get the whole Gestalt of the
situation and you
my years of training and experience to
hope for an inspiration which we did get
of how to adapt a standard Eevee a tool
and use it in a unconventional manner to
fix the problem so we described the
problem in our proposed solution to
Mission Control in words and we sent
down lots of TV pictures to give them
the best how should you say it the best
virtual impression of what we were
seeing
but somehow the people in the ground
just didn't seem to get it in the way
that we did they came up with lots of
suggestions which we didn't think would
work in one which we even thought would
damage the telescope and they were
afraid on the other hand that what we
wanted to do was going to damage the
telescope and I'm not really sure if
even the best virtual reality tools that
exist could have bridged the gap in the
end after considerable discussion the
flight director made a command decision
that since NASA had gone to a lot of
trouble to train us and send us up into
space we were there and could understand
the situation better than they could on
the ground then in the end they needed
to trust us and let us use our judgment
and get on with our plan which we did
successfully it's certainly true that in
unplanned time critical situations
humans are far more efficient and
flexible than even our best robots now
deciding whether to use humans or
machines for various tasks isn't limited
to space I mean we deal with this issue
in factory assembly lions in surgical
operating rooms deep in the ocean on
military battlefields and in general
decisions about using humans or
automated systems in most endeavors are
made on the basis of utility and
economics but for various historical and
sociological reasons which probably
would be a good thesis topic in space
policy the questions of humans and
robots in space has assumed almost the
nature of a religious conflict which I
think is unfortunate I would prefer to
deal with the issue more dispassionately
and maybe looking at a few examples will
help I mean you take surgery where
robotic
assistance already allow doctors to
operate with more precision than human
fingers can provide now of course these
are all teleoperated systems they should
really be considered I think as ultra
sophisticated tools for the surgeon I
mean after all it isn't the surgeon's
finger that does the cutting in the
first place it's the scalpel and so what
do we care if there's an additional tool
between the surgeons hand and the
scalpel and even if the operator is in a
remote location we're gonna have other
surgeons and assistants standing by in
case something goes wrong because
generally these robotic systems are
designed for very specific tasks things
can get a bit emotional if you're a moan
if you're talking about automating a
factory and workers are afraid that
they're gonna lose their job but this
isn't a religious fervor it's bread and
butter economics and in the military
field it's certainly true there are
pilots who are not happy about the
possibility of losing their primary role
in aerial warfare with the advent of
unmanned aerial vehicles but in all the
military services I actually I was
looking for Army Navy Air Force and
Marines I couldn't find any marine UAVs
and maybe you can't replace a marine by
a machine
I don't know but in any case the
decisions on adopting these automated
combat systems ultimately are going to
get made on the basis of cost and
strategic and tactical effectiveness and
of course the added factor of trying to
minimize casualties to our own troops
and finally oceanographic research and
deepwater commercial operations are
another example of sharing tasks between
remotely operated systems and systems
where humans travel to the work sites
now currently ocean systems don't have a
whole lot of onboard artificial
intelligence and so almost all ocean
systems whether they're tethered or not
are what we would call teleoperated but
even the human carrying system such as
Alvin here which by the way this is a
new altitude record for Alvin in the
other direction
even with these systems you don't put
human hands in direct contact with the
deep ocean environment humans certainly
have on-site presence but they work via
manipulators and other tools I've
actually spoken recently with the
director of Woods Hole about this
question of human and robotic choices in
ocean work and he tells me that actually
more and more it's true that unmanned
systems are used for commercial tasks
tasks and for reconnaissance they're
very good at taking pictures they're
cheaper to operate they don't involve
risk to humans however Alvin still seems
to be to have an advantage for
collecting useful rock samples and also
core samples now he's not sure if this
advantage is going to persist 10 years
or 15 years from now as robotic systems
improve but he also mentioned another
difference which was much harder to
quantify because he told me that he and
his colleagues really look forward to
their dives being inside Alvin at great
depths and the inside it really looks a
lot like a like a spaceship here and
when they're in there it focuses their
minds and it gives them a sense of the
environment in which they're working in
a way that they never ever experience
when they're working with remote
submersibles sitting around consoles up
on the surface and he really considers
this he calls it ocean awareness that
it's valuable in directing his research
and when I heard him say that I really
did feel an echo of the feelings I tried
to describe to you before that I heard
when I was working on Hubble just before
I returned to space exploration I'll end
this digression into other human robotic
areas with a quote from Scientific
American on deep-sea exploration and
scientific American is a pretty
reasonable publication they say most
scientists involved in exploration of
deep ocean of the deep ocean have moved
away from human occupied submersibles
toward robotic
they're relatively inexpensive and of
course carry no risk to a human operator
indeed remotely operated vehicles have
become so popular as tools for the
offshore shore oil industry
that economic forces could soon render
conventional submersibles extinct but
for humans to lose altogether the
ability to explore the ocean depths in
person would be unfortunate quite aside
from the question of whether some subsea
jobs can best be done by someone on the
scene this loss would be a blow to the
human spirit of adventure for these
reasons it seems a worthwhile goal to
develop a better class of deep-sea
submersibles not to replace remote or
autonomous vehicles but to offer a
complimentary in situ capability for
those who want it
well maybe the last part of this quote
sort of approaches being quasi-religious
in its overtones but I think it's
basically a balanced view of the utility
of human and robotic systems that could
also apply to many activities in space
personally I loved robots in space I
mean they have taken me as close as I'll
ever get to the surface of Mars like
most of you when I watched the 97
Martian Pathfinder poking its way around
the surface up against rocks and finding
its way against opposite obstacles I
really had a sense of the presence of
human intelligence on the surface of
Mars
because while tools were originally
limited to enhancing human physical
capabilities modern technology has
really made it possible to use two tools
to project human presence now I wouldn't
talk about robots competing with people
in exploring space any more than I would
talk about robots competing with
telescopes think about humanity's most
distant physical Explorer which is
Voyager 1 which is now about Oh 12
billion miles away from the Sun a little
over 12 light hours which is about 0.03
of a percent of the distance to Alpha
Centauri it's been traveling a long time
and it hasn't even left our own
heliosphere and I don't want
get bogged down in the details of the
geometry of the universe but in a sense
we can say that our robotic probes have
access to about roughly one part in 10
to the 30th maybe of the volume of the
universe that's accessible to our
telescopes so we can dream of sending
probes to the stars but barring the
realization of some science-fiction
Space Warp technology almost the entire
volume of the universe is going to have
to be explored with telescopes and not
with robotic probes now when we come
inside our own solar system and we put
telescopes and other remote sensing z'
in orbit around celestial bodies oh no
well so what do I do here I'll just push
okay I do my best to test all these
things out before we start and then they
hit me at the end
okay virtual memory is low so it goes in
any case so here we are getting a nice
look much better than then we can get
with telescopes around our own earth and
of course they give us a much better
view of the surfaces when they're in
orbit and if we have machines that can
actually land and manipulate objects on
the surface of another planet this gives
us tremendous power to explore much
beyond just looking or even taking in
situ measurements I mean good vision is
essential but touch and maneuverability
takes us into another dimension of
control over the environment being
explored you know in places where robots
can get to they can do things that
telescopes can't and there's nothing so
complicated or controversial about this
in places that people can get to we can
do things that robots can't do it's just
that it's a lot harder and riskier and
generally a lot more expensive to send
people than robots just as it's harder
riskier and more expensive to send
robots than to look through a telescope
there's really very little area of
overlap I mean the farthest away from
home that human beings have ever
explored is the moon which is less than
a half a million kilometers away and we
didn't stay very long and even when we
get to Mars someday which we will I
won't say when but we will but even when
we get there human beings will still
have reached only a tiny fraction of the
domain which is already accessible today
to our robotic probes just as our robots
have only reached a fraction of the
domain explored by our telescopes and
that's what I really meant when I said
at the beginning that most space
exploration has been and always will be
done by machines
meaning telescopes satellites probes and
robots but where people have gone we've
done things that machine's could not do
and we've experienced these environments
as human beings and we can discuss the
flexibilities that humans bring to
carrying out scientific experiments in
space it's important but we also need to
remember that there are other types of
knowledge besides scientific and human
presence can make a big difference in
communicating the experiences of new
environments in ways that go beyond
science think about the Earth's polar
regions the land of the Midnight Sun and
of the Aurora which we see here from
space these are areas of intense
exploration and research activities now
I've never been to Alaska or the Yukon
probably few of us in this room have
ever been there but I suspect that every
one of us has an idea of what these
Arctic regions are like and I wonder how
much of our general perception of what's
it like to be in the Arctic comes from
scientific journals and how much comes
from Jack London's famous short story to
light a fire
because exploration goes beyond science
people realize this intrinsically when
they're asking that question what's it
like to truly know an environment in
human terms
especially to communicate what that
environment is like can often require
art as well as science and it helps to
be there Alan bean was an astronaut who
landed on the moon on Apollo 12 back in
late 1969 and 10 years later Allen was
the mentor of our group of young
astronaut recruits and I was impressed
here's an old Navy fighter pilot but we
enjoyed talking together about
literature and art and Allen eventually
left NASA to try his hand as a full-time
artist and he said he wanted some way
other than words or photographs to
express what it looked like on the moon
what has experienced experiences were
being there now most of the lunar
landscape is certainly very well
represented by black and white
photographs and the only color in this
picture comes from the human artifacts
that we put there when Allen looked at
the rich variety of surface textures at
Hadley rill which in this case was
explored by Apollo 15 and it was a
magnificent sight to explore probably
the most visually impressive of all the
regions explored during Apollo but Allen
knew would it look like to the people
who were there and he tried to express
the variety of texture through an almost
impressionistic use of color now Allen
would be the first person to tell you
that the moon doesn't necessarily really
look like this
any more than the Rouen Cathedral or the
haystacks that Monet painted so many
times really appeared literally in all
those colors but for me Allen has showed
something of what it's like to be on the
moon that I never would have been able
to experience just from looking at a
photograph now certainly robots may not
write books or paint pictures but as I
said there will always be places that
our robots can go where our bodies can't
follow
so if exploration is ultimately the
expansion of human consciousness then we
need to do everything
we can do to enable our minds and our
spirits to follow our robots where our
physical bodies can't go so future space
exploration needs to use all the virtual
reality tools that we possess to put
ourselves inside our robots to use
robotic presence to extend our sensory
experience because our consciousness
consciousness of the world is ultimately
tied to our sensory experience of the
world so I think actually the Media Lab
should be playing as large a role in
future exploration as places which are
designing new propulsion system when we
go through the list of our senses
actually with vision we already can do
pretty well I mean given proper sensors
on the lunar surface and sufficient
telemetry bandwidth you know we still
have a little problem with peripheral
vision but nevertheless I could stand on
the earth look around and have almost
the same visual experience that Alan
bean had standing on the moon and sound
isn't going to be a problem if we're in
an environment where sound is important
I mean the the ill-fated Mars 98 land or
actually had a microphone on it which
would have led us here the wind and the
dust on the surface of Mars and maybe
even the sound of the shovel digging in
Martian soil and eventually we will have
a microphone there to complement the
visual with the auditory sense
experience the senses of taste and smell
well I don't know if any of you are
familiar with Norman Mailer's book about
the Apollo program it's called up a fire
on the moon it's an interesting book in
it he says that ultimately to know the
moon as human beings we need to be able
to smell a lunar rock I think he had
this same idea in mind about sensory
experience it's a nice thought I'd love
to try it if I could get my hands on the
lunar rock but in general taste and
smell plays such a small role in human
society that we've never even bothered
to develop technologies to transmit
these senses over a distance so I
certainly don't see the lack of virtual
smell and taste as a significant barrier
to space exploration but touch the fifth
sense of course is something else
completely because as I already said the
ability to manipulate the environment
that we're exploring is critical so to
really expand human presence into a new
environment we need to incorporate
sophisticated haptic that is touch
feedback systems into our space robots
given sufficiently sophisticated visual
and haptic feedback I can certainly
imagine putting a mobile version of
Robonaut on the surface of the Moon and
having back on the earth a good part of
the experience not just obscene but now
actually of exploring the lunar surface
yeah we have a two second round-trip
light travel time but that's short
enough so with sufficient training you
could guide a robotic partner around the
surface of the Moon almost as if you
yourself were there on the spot and you
would eventually come to feel that a
significant fraction of your
consciousness was present on the surface
of the Moon I mean that's the nature of
virtual reality to create a convincing
internally perceived environment not
only would it be great fun but it would
be an incredibly powerful tool for lunar
exploration but when we extrapolate this
to Mars
not to mention farther out in the solar
system we have to face the problem of
the finite speed of light now I've
talked with robotic specialists about
predictive algorithms optimized
feed-forward loops and they say that it
that if you've got all these things
organized properly the humans can
actually operate a robotic system with
up to a five or six second time lag with
not too much loss of efficiency as long
as the environment isn't changing too
fast but you know with other planets
we're talking about minutes or hours not
seconds now we can certainly transmit
back sufficiently sophisticated
information from Mars to permit
reconstructing a virtual presence after
the fact so you can use your computer
mouse and fly virtually through Martian
canyons
it's really exciting but the idea of
interactive virtual presence changes
fundamentally as you increase the
communication travel time
flying a computer mouse through a
virtual Canyon is a lot different from
controlling a real airplane flying
through real canyons where you can
really crash into the walls
now obviously from a strictly technical
robotic point of view what we want to do
is build more intelligence and autonomy
into our robots so that they can do a
maximum of useful work on their own
while they're waiting to communicate
with us but the degree to which
autonomous robots far away in the solar
system are ever going to give us a real
conscious awareness of new environments
is going to be far less than totally
interactive real-time virtual reality
and of course the speed of exploration
will be a lot slower now I don't foresee
this as a long term impediment to
exploring Mars because as I said
eventually we're going to have human
beings on Mars because it's such a
fascinating place with abundant evidence
of a real of a rich geologic history
that once we have the capability to send
people there for a reasonable cost
whatever that is and with reasonable
risk whatever that is I have no doubt
that we're going to do it and it'll be
in large part because the results of our
telescopic and robotic exploration of
Mars will have been so exciting that
people will feel that they want to get
to know this planet as well as is
humanly possible and that's the key as
well as is humanly possible because
ultimately the best vessel to carry
human consciousness into a new
environment is the human body but when
we go we're not going to throw away our
robots just the opposite human explorers
on Mars are almost surely going to
exercise real-time control over armies
of exploration robots and they'll mostly
be autonomous but susceptible when
necessary to real-time assistance to
overcome problems beyond their
capability to solve we don't necessarily
have to develop robots that are as good
at complex decision-making as human
beings for them to be useful explorers
especially if the human being Explorer
is near
to redirect them when something
unexpected happens and they don't know
how to proceed and of course to fix them
when they break
I mean imagine what one human Explorer
could do with a flock of robots even as
smart as say an average sheep what I'm
looking or a dog much better but in any
case what I'm looking forward to in a
sense is a symbiosis between human and
robotic exploration because each makes
the other more efficient and the closer
together they are physically the more
opportunities there are for symbiosis
one of the strongest lures for exploring
Mars is the indication that in the past
it was almost surely very different from
the dry desert that it seems to be today
and learning the detailed history of
Mars I'm sure is someday going to occupy
the attention of as many field
geologists as we can support on the
surface of the planet I have yet to meet
a field geologist who believes that they
could explore as well using robots as in
person because field geology is a highly
interactive highly unstructured activity
with lots of surprises being the norm
and that's just the sort of activity in
which humans excel in the long term once
we have the capability to transport and
support people far away from the earth
ultimately we'll have to decide which
environments are interesting enough to
warrant this additional exploration
capability that humans can provide I
mean Mars certainly will require a lot
of human effort to fully explore but
would say a hundred metre diameter
asteroid be worth the trouble of human
exploration I don't know we'll have to
decide as far as Mars goes if current
hunches are correct our field geologists
will eventually almost surely be joined
by some drilling rig Roughnecks to
prospect for subsurface water and then
once the scale of human activity on Mars
gets large enough we'll need support
personnel as well to maintain scientific
basis take care of all the logistical
activities necessary to support human
survival in such a hostile and
I mean that's the way things are in
Antarctica but in addition to vastly
extending the range of scientific
exploration that can be carried out on
the surface of Mars beyond what robots
could do on their own I would certainly
hope that at least one of these human
explorers on Mars will turn out to be
another Jack London who will be able to
give the rest of us who we are never
going to go there a sense of what Mars
is really like not just the data not
just the views but a sense of what it's
like to be on Mars and when this time
comes and we have the technology and the
economic means and the political will
for humans to explore Mars I'm
absolutely sure that at the same time
we'll be working on sophisticated
robotic exploration of the outer solar
system and perhaps beyond
I mean if terrestrial planet finder
actually does find earth-like planets
around neighboring stars aren't we
ultimately going to want a closer look
developing the artificial intelligence
and those self-repair capabilities that
are going to be required for robotic
interstellar probes is probably going to
be easier than developing a civilization
with sufficient social stability and
foresight to be willing to undertake
exploration on a timescale of decades or
centuries but in any case the parallel
of challenges of future space
exploration are going to be to push the
outer boundaries of robotic exploration
into realms previously explored only by
telescopes and at the same time to push
the boundaries of human presence into
realms previously explored only by
robots so let me end my talk with a
metaphor for exploring space it's an
expanding sphere of human consciousness
and experience which is composed of
three layers on the outside is the
overwhelmingly large part of the
universe that's accessible only to
passive sensing and then tens of orders
of magnitude smaller
is that part of the universe that we can
physically interact with through
autonomous and remotely controlled
machines but with the level of virtual
human presence limited by the speed of
light and then in a volume smaller by
tens of orders of magnitude still will
be that part of the universe that humans
can experience directly with no speed of
light compromises now I would like to
see all three of these layers grow how
fast they grow is going to depend on
lots of different factors most of which
we probably can't even imagine but much
less be able to predict that's the
challenge we face whether we're enabling
people to live and work more comfortably
and efficiency efficiently in low-earth
orbit or searching for water and life on
Mars or sending probes to Pluto and the
Kuiper belt or studying the atmosphere
of planets revolving around nearby stars
or observing quasars over thirteen
billion light-years away we're expanding
this multi-layer sphere of human
experience exploration brings us to
places we haven't been before and I've
been very fortunate to experience
directly a little bit of this new world
of space and I have to say it's always a
pleasure to relive some of my
experiences with a sympathetic audience
of course there's a lot of space left to
explore and one of the exciting things
that I've found here at MIT is how many
of us are explorers in a whole wonderful
variety of ways so I thank you again for
inviting me to share some of my ideas
about how space exploration may
ultimately proceed and and I look
forward to exploring together
[Applause]
with training you're usually where
planetary protection is not something
I'm going to answer in you know
one-minute answer to a question and I
suspect that the answer is is every bit
as much political as technical from a
technical point of view I mean maybe we
will try to heat sterilize the first
samples samples because you won't
destroy all the information in them
ultimately we have to have a way to be
able to convince the public at large
that that it is safe to bring back
samples not just from Mars but you know
we're going to be bringing back samples
from comets we're bringing back samples
of the solar wind you know there's lots
of pieces of space that are going to be
brought back to the earth to study and
we need to convince people and convince
ourselves that we can do it safely
humans and so by ending up with the
Antarctic research station brings up an
interesting possibility NSF supports
artists to go to the research station
why haven't parts tree nuts well I'll
tell you there are incredible artistic
possibilities making use of the
environment in space you know to have
things that can float you know kinetic
sculptures I didn't show any pictures
here of what it's like when you do a
water dump out of the shuttle and you
get these ice crystals coming all over
the place lit up and they're like little
prisms glittering in the in the sunlight
which are just earth you know
breathtakingly beautiful there's a
there's a whole aesthetic environment to
be pursued and and that's a good example
of part of the human experience of
getting to know a new environment which
you don't get just by sending a remote
probe although cameras take pretty
beautiful pictures in any case but yeah
I'd love to see space explored
artistically as well as scientifically
because it is a fascinating environment
Minh same story no matter what astronaut
you and you if you asked the Apollo
astronauts the ones who came in towards
the end of the program said we'll never
mind if I'll get to fly to the moon
because in 10 years I'll be flying to
Mars when when we came in as new
astronauts in 1978 everybody was sure
that you know by the end of the century
we'd have scientific bases on on the
moon and on Mars I don't know I don't
know I mean it's it's a goal which
recedes in the future there are there
are sociological and economic reasons to
explain why Apollo in fact was was
probably an anomaly historically rather
than the way space exploration is going
to be done in the future and I think on
the one hand it was a magnificent
endeavor and everybody who was alive at
the time of Apollo was fortunate to have
been able to experience it but for
people who look at it as the model of
how we're going to get to Mars it can be
a curse which I think has infused
certainly the NASA mentality for decades
and and we still haven't quite figured
out another way to do it and until we do
the goal is going to continue to recede
presentation to chat first for those
students in the modern space science of
engineering the classroom type area
myself waited at the back of me without
the refreshment circuit cardinality
I'd like to thank Helen towers who was
organized
[Applause]
[Music]
go away on sabbatical Jeff and I are
looking France we won't have to work on
May the first
[Music]
and finally it was not take advantage of
our viewer here to place a classified
our before half-time assistant directors
Massachusetts paper
interesting
we have a certificate of appreciation of
the Massachusetts been spared
construction to dr. Jeffrey Kaufman for
you I'm sure you all agree is an
outstanding
[Applause]